so we're going to focus on four
different states today having to do with
coronavirus
and there are different policies being
texas and florida and california and new
york and we're going to look at
different data
number one out of the 500 billion dollar
relief that we gave which state got the
most
and outside of that whose unemployment
is the lowest who's responding better to
coronavirus and what kind of decisions
they're making
but prior to doing that let's look at
the one data here because
as you're thinking about the percentages
of people dying i wanted to unpack and
go to cdc and see in what age category
is dying the most and i want to do
specific statistics on this so let's
take a look
so according to cdc website if you go
here 27 kids under the age of 1
have died from cronovirus
under the age of one there are 3.7
million
kids under the age of one so out of
3.783 million
27 have died which i absolutely
sympathize with that family
but the percentage of death is point
zero
zero zero seven percent if we go to one
to four
sixteen have died that's a population of
fifteen point seven million
in america meaning out of the 15.7
million ages 1 to 416
you're looking at 0.0001
of that population has died if you go to
5 to 14
40 kids have died 40.994 million
population you do the math right there
you will see it's point zero zero zero
zero
nine eight at least amongst the three
okay least amongst the three
but if you add them up any anybody under
the age of 14 you're looking at 56
76 83 83 on roughly
60 million have died so the reason why
i'm showing you this is because i have
kids and my kids are going to school
and if we look at the policies of texas
against texas and florida
new york and california new york just
announced they shut down schools
new york has a curfew with bars and
restaurants i believe from 10 o'clock
till 6 in the morning
california just announced their shuttle
they shut down schools in july
indefinitely for the rest of the year
and it's all homeschooling right now
they just announced they're shutting
down
and they're putting a curfew from 10 to
5 a.m for non-essential industries and
then they just
announced la is potentially shutting
down period everyone's staying at home
they're saying they may announce it as
of sunday you may watch this video as of
tuesday it may have already been
announced but that's the policy so now
watch this when you look at the data
like this
we know kids are not affected by which
means why shut down schools
i don't know but let's continue so now
let's go to the next age category
15 to 24 418 have died from coronavirus
that's 43 million people in that
population 15 to 24. if you do the math
we're looking at point zero zero zero
one two nine percent
25 to 34 that's 1769 45 million
35 to 44 4500 have died that's 41
million so look at 40 40 40 40. all of
those are 40.
45 to 54 12 000 of that you see that
number tripling a little bit
in that age category it's also 40
million and in 55 to 64 you're going
higher if 29 000 have died
on 42 million of that population have
died 29 000
of that population have that if you go
to the math here even in that is point
zero
six eight three five six percent
of that specific population so now let's
go to the top now look at the top here
65 to 74 75 to 84 85 and up right let's
take a look at this
specific stat 49 862 between 65 to 74
have died
31 million that's a number right there
that we have to be looking at
which is point one five eight three
seven five percent of that entire
population
has died okay if you go 75 to 84 61
860 we're looking at 15.969 now we're at
0.387 percent
of that population has died anybody
above 85 million
uh 71 000 is the highest amongst all the
age categories and it's the smallest
population
except for under one which means that's
basic math has the highest percentage
dying
71 000 above 85 000 have died uh above
85 years old have died
you take that out of the 6.6 million one
percent
of anybody ages 85 plus has died
okay period from coronavirus one percent
which means
we have to do whatever we can to protect
this community
of 65 and up that doesn't mean shutting
down everything that doesn't mean
shutting down schools
that doesn't mean shutting down any of
that stuff it just means shutting down
this basic thing here now
so as i got a little bit deeper and
started looking at what california and
new york are doing shut down let's shut
down the economy
florida and texas are saying no no let's
keep it open we don't need to shut down
everything matter of fact
abbott just came out saying we are
definitely not shutting down the economy
and desantis came out of saying we're
not shutting down the economy the only
thing that's going on in florida is
miami-dade county
put a curfew i believe it's from 12
o'clock to 6 a.m or
you know something like that it's a very
small curfew but they do have a curfew
set up
aside from that it's business as usual
right now watch what happens here
if you come a little closer and you look
at some of the data
for cases right texas is leading the way
with the most cases 1.1 million million
california's got 1 million 94.
florida's got 923 000 and in new york
is 623. our focus is those four four
states right
now remember republican democrat
republican democrat
very basic because it's about policies
then when we come and look at the data
on stats
when it comes down to unemployment by
state watch unemployment by state
if we look at the top unemployment by
state i have it over here
where it's going to be even easier to
find unemployment by state
new york is at 9.6 unemployment
california is at 9.3 percent
unemployment all you have to do is to
find those states go all the way to the
bottom
new york 9.6 california
it's very easy 9.3
and if you want to find florida or texas
go about the middle
6.9 florida 6.5
it's as if new york and california are
on a different text distribution system
and florida and texas are in a complete
distribution system when it comes down
to texting
now watch this come a little closer to
me here
we gave 500 billion dollars when i say
we that means you and i because we have
to pay that in taxes
we gave the relief of 500 billion
dollars to states
look what states led the way with taking
the most out of that 500 billion
dollars california took 21.6 billion
allocation year one
27.8 allocation year 2 billion not
million billion
that's 12.49 per capita 12.49 per capita
and then if you go to florida they took
12.3 million half
if you look at florida year two 11.8 but
if you look at capital even per capita
is lower look at dc what they took by
the way 46.43 i mean that's like theft
what dc did right there
taking the most obviously that's where
the politicians live now if you live if
you go to texas
we're looking at 15.8 18.4 per capita
and if we look at the last one which is
what new york 21.7 13.1 per capita
the highest amongst the four states so
again we bailed out you and i
bailed out new york and california and
new york and california needed more than
texas
and florida here's how it looks like
imagine having four kids
and two of your kids always call you for
allowance daddy i need money
mom send me more money i can't do it on
my own i need you to bail me out mom
please send me more money that's new
york and california for you
texas and florida like mom we're good we
got i mean if you want to it's cool but
we got them all we got we got
dad we're good we're totally good you
can you can you know trust us we got
everything under control
okay and obviously it's not perfect but
they got things in control very
interesting perspective
on how these two states are handling
this thing so now while i'm going a
little bit deeper
i said you know what i want to do here's
what i want to do i
wonder what role are exercising and
going out their place in our immune
system
does it help us not get more viruses and
what i did is i specifically went back
and found
articles pre-2020 because any articles
you read write about immune system it'll
say
exercise doesn't have anything to do
with strengthening your immune system
because it validates the argument of
well we can close gyms people don't need
to exercise watch this here
so the first article i went to was from
uh webmd you've heard of webmd and the
article is not a recent one this is a
couple years back when they wrote this
but watch what it says
um myth and fact about your immune
system okay myth and facts about your
immune system
a positive attitude can be healthy
meaning if you exercise
a positive attitude can be healthy so if
i got a positive attitude
a good outlook maybe a good maybe good
for your health one study of law
students showed that their immune system
kept pace
with their thoughts about how tough
school would be when they felt better
about school they had a better immune
system
when they were worried their immune
system slowed down the upshot looking on
the bright side might be a
equip your body to fight illnesses let
me read this part
when they were worried their immune
system slow down
ready you tell me how worried people are
today
so news media covet oh my gosh people
are dying
everybody's worried immune system goes
lower based on not what i'm saying i'm
not i'm not saying this webmd is saying
this right now watch this let's go to
the next one
mayo clinic you ever heard of mayo
clinic everybody's heard of mayo clinic
they're known as the pinnacle to go to
look what it says
about the benefits top 10 reasons to get
physical
top 10 reasons to get physical look what
it says here number one
keeps excess pounds at bay great number
two increase your stamina fitness and
strength
number three ready word off viral
illnesses
aerobic exercise activates your immune
system in a good way this may leave you
less susceptible
to minor viral illnesses such as colds
and flu
uh this was written in february 5th 2020
which means
they kind of know what they were talking
about by the way in february we haven't
shut down the economy yet
coronavirus is not that big yet it's
just kind of getting started
so this is right before that saying it's
better if you exercise
yet california and new york want to shut
down everything so you can't go out
there and exercise
and they're putting so much fear in you
your immune system goes lower because
you're negative so two things right
there to be thinking about
on how this is helping or not helping
those states now let's continue
because of a phenomenal job new york did
guess what they decided to do to do new
york governor
andrew cuomo will receive an emmy for
showing leadership during his daily
covet 19 press briefings what a hero
right
let me show you another stat here take a
look at this how we recognize people
death by state number one new york 33
784 new york has the most death
by state texas number two california
number three
florida number four and if you look at
this they have the highest death
and out of those four states to have the
lowest population now some may say it
was because of condensations people are
around each other
the highest death the lowest and they
were bailed out by the government and he
is not getting an emmy
and on top of that california is
imposing the curfew
la county is thinking about shutting
down this sunday possible stay at home
and on top of this if you haven't seen
the other article that came out
with our buddy newsome what he's doing
which is a beautiful thing
he goes to french laundry this is an
article that came out sitting on
november 6
when governor newsom sat down for dinner
fancy dinner party at
tony napa valley restaurant the french
laundry the state was in the midst of a
code 19 search newsome and other state
officials were emphasizing
the importance of following social
distancing rules and wearing face masks
and public places as mandated by an
order
that the governor issued in june and he
goes to in french
french laundry a restaurant and he eats
there with his friends
good for him the one thing i will tell
him is he came back and apologized which
is good for him
and then even new york times did an
article on him saying for california
governor the coronavirus message is do
as i say
not as i died so why am i sharing this
with you the reason why i'm sharing this
with you is because everything
comes down to policies this is not about
this is not about the person of cuomo i
like when i see cuomo brothers on
i get entertained by them i think i
would have a phenomenal time with them
thanksgiving watching football
i think they're the kinds of guys that
they're probably you know taking shots
sarcasm military
that kind of an environment which i like
i was in the military i like that
environment
but i'm specifically talking policies
newsome i don't know newsom for all i
know is he may be a good guy
but i know his policies his policies
are hurting the people in the state of
california state i lived there for 24
years
new york's policies are hurting parents
who want their kids to go back to school
and the scientists which i don't know
i've never met
abbott whom i've never met i've never
spoken to their policies
are more calm saying it's okay brighter
side
brighter side webmd it's good to look at
the brighter side
it's good to look at great times are
around the corner this vaccine's coming
things are going to get better brighter
side brighter side
go out there and exercise get some sun
get your body to do better your immune
system is going to get stronger
and their unemployment is in the sixes
california new york is in heinz you know
how hard it is when you lose your
business i said this many many times
when somebody loses their business they
don't go start another business
when you lose your business you have to
go get a job and it's tough to get a job
after you lose a business because now
you're kind of looking and saying what
am i going to do
you have to take anything you have to
take so this is not necessarily just
about
who has more death and who doesn't have
more debt this is about
which policies are giving people a
brighter future
texas and florida right now are winning
new york and california right now
are getting hammered and the people are
leaving
left and right out of those two states
and people are staying put in texas and
florida
and those from new york are going to
florida and those from california
are coming to texas if you watch this
video you want to go a little bit deeper
about a video like this i want to hear
your thoughts comment below but i also
did a video comparing what
the policies of california florida
disneyland
and disney world disneyland's in
california disney world
is in florida watch how the two policies
forced the same company to fire 28 000
people in california
and keep their employees in the state of
florida if you've now watched that video
click over here to watch that video
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye